have you seen the teaser trailer yet for
Pacific Rim Guillermo del Toro's new
movie you get the idea it's basically
giant robots fighting giant monsters
orally parlance of us nerds mecha versus
kaiju right the mecca of them robots the
kaiju are the monsters uh you know am I
gonna go see that whoa yeah I'm gonna go
see that so are you I mean we're gonna
be there um I grew up on a diet of this
stuff right macross and giant robo I
mean my twitter handle is actually a a
miss hearing misremembering a corruption
of the name of a giant robot from a
Godzilla movie I mean I I'm down I'm
into this stuff right but I say all that
as as preface to say that if you really
think about it giant humanoid robots are
a terrible terrible idea this is an
awful weapon let me explain what I mean
so um I have nothing against bipedalism
right I mean I'm into it but uh we're
really unstable I mean yeah okay it's
good to have our heads high up right we
get to be have 3d vision and look around
and we get to use our nifty opposable
thumbs but you kick out a leg and we're
down right and that's exactly what a
giant monster is going to do right you
go for the vulnerable parts vulnerable
parts boy you know this is a what you
see now is a blueprint nominally from
the movie they call the giant robots the
mecca jakers in it and they this is part
of the marketing let's just come out and
you can see is this now this looks to me
you tell me if I'm wrong this looks to
me like the cockpit of these things is
in the head our brains are fairly well
protected inside cranium right big thick
skull but this is a target man I mean
you put the cockpit on top of a giant
robot and it's just asking to get hit by
a big lizard tail or atomic breath or
something right i mean at least in the
gun damn movies and i thicken the neon
genesis stuff they had the good sense to
put the cockpits in the chest where
they're a little more protected right i
mean it's not like you need room for
lungs or something and I mean seriously
like putting the cockpit where the
controls are in the head of a giant
robot is as stupid as like
putting the bridge of a starship on the
top of a giant saucer where everybody
actually scratch that let's go on to
something else I don't get it I don't
understand why you would want a giant
robot like to carry a gun like they do
in patlabor like why would you have a
separate gun it's not like they have a
lot of fingers again look I get building
big you're finding a godzilla-sized
monster they can take out a whole bridge
you need something giant I'm even into
maybe not bio morph is embarking other
kinds of models like I like the Yamato
built in the giant ship right but with
the wave motion gun on the front how
about we send giant flying spaceships
that used to go in the water against the
giant robots I'm into that actually what
I'm really into is building something a
little more stable and something that
could still pick its way over and study
ground right like legs could but
actually has wheels too so what I like
are the tachikoma is from ghost in the
shell stand alone complex right they
look like spiders they have a lot of
legs they're very stable they're low to
the ground they're heavily armed granted
they have the small problem of achieving
self-awareness and then rebelling
against their creators but I think
that's a small price to pay for a weapon
that actually could stand up to a kaiju